他结婚四十四五年了吧，
然后也有一个孩子，
然后现在孩子也是十四五岁了，
就20就已经生上来了，
已经是35岁了，
但是现在是跟他分居了，
分居了三四年，
然后就是他的天津，
我在北京就是这样，
我的自己上班养活自己的呢，
就是我还帮我确定一下之后怎么跟这个孩子相处，
或者说我跟他分开，
是不是正确的选择这个孩子呢，
首先就是从小我肯定就是我带的比较少，
就是从小就是我婆婆他们带他，
我跟他分居之前啊，
最后一次我回去看我孩子，
然后那个孩子呢，
就是也挺叛逆的时候，
现在可能就十八四岁，
我说什么他也不听，
跟我动手，
我说这两次动一下子把我推倒在地上，
就是挺暴力的那种感觉，
他平常也从来不联系，
就回去看他之前啊，
我也不知道谁逗他的，
他可能说啊，
我手机坏了，
我说行，
那我给你买一个邮回去，
然后我就给他买一个手机，
买完手机后来我回去看他之后，
反正也挺暴力的对我动手，
一个大小伙子，
1米8大高个儿，
我也想过去，
后来我就真的挺伤心挺伤心的，
然后第二天我就走了，
走了之后给这个孩子就再也没有联系过，
嗯，
到现在也没联系过，
可能也没有多少感情吧，
想说这个孩子以后，
你说长大了，
现在以后怎么跟他相处呀，
还有就是联这个必要，
我觉得这事啊，
嗯，
是这样子，
因为你们。
本身他小的时候你带的少，
他难免是跟爷爷奶奶啊，
可能会有点溺爱啊，
那现在这个年龄啊，
他有点叛逆啊，
尽量在心里别怨他，
别恨他，
别怪他，
就当他是叛逆期了，
男人实话实说，
就算自己亲自带到他到叛逆期的时候，
也有可能就是脾气一上来了，
就这那的，
就像我哥小的时候，
我印象当中就有这么一个阶段，
那个阶段的话，
他看谁都不顺眼，
他看谁都是属于那种横眉冷对的那个状态，
但是这事儿的话，
也看他自己的发展，
他自己如果能够成长为一个，
有一种嗯，
感恩之心，
对母亲有这个思念，
这样的话，
咱们就好好的相处，
但如果他实在要成长为一个，
比如说对谁都很怨恨，
对谁都没有什么好脸色，
他要可以成长为那样的人的话，
咱也改变不了，
因为现在毕竟是这个状态了，
已经这么大了，
你也改变不了什么了，
但是你还要不要去联系他呢？
那我觉得啊，
从我们自己的这个角度，
当妈妈的这个角度，
该给他买鞋子还得买，
该给他买衣服还得买，
该给他买什么好吃的还得买，
就这衣服平你还在从矮点可以寄回去嘛，
就一米八八，
穿多大的衣服，
两个叉，
矮老了，
衣服就是该给他买还给他买，
等他以后慢慢自己长大吧，
他如果实在长成那个很。
冷漠的对你没有一丝一毫的想念的这样一个状态，
可能咱们也就释怀了，
等他长大了就释怀了，
这的责就是我该买什么买什么啊，
他如果感恩的话，
就机持联系，
他如果不感恩就有人的话不联系无所谓了，
等他18岁，
他自己已经嗯成年了，
或者他自己都已经工作了，
他实在对你没有一点感恩，
没有一点思念之情的话，
可能就是你们这一世的母子缘分，
且然后我在想说一下，
就是刚孩子他爸的那个，
那我都不知道我离开是不是正确的，
我反而帮我分析一下，
他现在找人了吧，
就是分开之前也是在一起住了半年，
但是那半年从来没有说话，
就是猜到我是空气，
我当他是空气那种，
那个时候他已经找人了，
我已经就看到非常明显了，
他包里各种的其实没种药啊什么之类的东西我都看到了，
但是到现在的话，
我其实我也没有证据，
如果人家都已经往前走了，
人家都已经有人了，
这个时候我们不要回过头去再分析当时我跟他分居对还是不对了，
咱们就应该分析我接下来的日子该怎么过，
我才能把我剩余的岁月过好，
因为现在人家已经有人了，
你在分析说当时我走的是对还是错，
还有什么意义呢？
那你这没错，
用这个结果来看，
就离开家，
马上就有人了，
家。
都已经半年不跟你说话了，
那你选择就是对的，
分居是三四年了，
之间也没有联系过，
之前也谈过，
也可能协过协议，
他不同意，
然后就是我们婚后也是十来年，
之后也是一起买了个房子嘛，
反正就是刚开始我跟他一起的时候什么都没有，
后来他可能也是靠自己个拼己买了车买了房之类的，
跟他一起就是十几年，
就因为跟房子这个事儿他不愿意，
他就想买这个房子，
等孩子成年之后护理孩子，
他就是就想让我健身受户，
我就是感觉来正他这么长时间就感觉心里挺不甘心的那种，
如果这事儿啊，
就是你跟他分开都已经三四年了，
人家是靠他的努力买了房买了车，
就是这三四年对吧，
你也不在身边，
你也没有对他事业上有什么支持，
也没有对他情感上有什么慰藉，
那也能理解这个男人他不愿意分给你，
你换位思考一下吧，
假设说是你在这三四年当中，
你发展的特别好啊，
说你干网红了，
你一年挣50万了，
你一年挣100万了，
完了之后你买了房，
你买了车，
你也不愿意赠给他，
嗯感如果在他这年跟那个解，
如果我想别的孩就一直拖到现在，
我的十业年钱里就当然然是分居着，
那我现在就是说我找他，
然后我就可以，
我就是一直为了分这个财产，
就为了不甘心，
所以一直拖到现在，
那我现在听你这么说的话，
那我就可以去找他，
直接就协商，
他之前说过他啊给你5万块钱，
咱就。
起好不好，
但今天的车子房子存款了，
他们加起来房子那时候买的在不是特别贵啊，
也就60个买了，
然后我那车子也有20个，
然后加上上自己存款，
可能还一二十个，
也跟我们在一起的时候已经买房买车了，
只不不换车了，
那情况不一样，
如果是你们在一起的时候，
你们共同生活的时候，
共同奋斗的时候，
就买房买车的话，
那我觉得该打算咋分，
所以就你一直因为这个问题就到现在，
一直就你吧，
也没离成就拖到现在，
因为我岁数可能也不小了，
然后我家里人吧，
也是老师替我这个事儿操心，
然后让我赶紧干了，
干脆利索再出去给我介绍的这种，
你这个年纪当大之年，
姐妹啊，
35岁就当打之年，
如果说句难听点的话，
如果跟这个孩子母子缘分浅的话，
咱抓紧时间再生一个，
嗯，
对，
为他总共就20万存款吗？
如果能谈个10万块钱，
也可以考虑就和平分手了，
你说如果你不给我这个钱的话，
那咱俩就打官司，
该怎么分怎么分，
一人一半怎么分呗，
卡呢，
再去找他要10万块钱，
他能和平分手的，
和平离的话就离，
不能和平的话，
那我就起诉呗，
是，
那就这样呗。
因为他那有一些情况，
他要转移的怎么办？
嗯，
这个如果打官司的话，
是可以查他的流水，
查他的记录，
后来又把那个房子就给孩子，
我心里觉得有点不甘心，
就跟着他十几年，
反正就我觉得健生说过了，
如果说在这段婚姻当中，
确实也没有给他添柴加火啊，
也别老说你跟人家十几年了，
因为跟人家分居了三四年了，
别老这么想问题啊，
你得想往前看想，
我现在才35岁，
我当打之年，
你35岁多好的年纪，
我怎么能够以后在选择伴侣的时候更成熟更理性，
选择一个适合我的伴侣，
怎么能够跟孩子经营好这个母子之间的感情，
你往这个方向去想，
这十几年可能是你该交的学费呢，
自己该成长的这样一个过程呢，
这么想问题。